wnba's star center brittany greiner has
been detained in russia
in february after police found vape
canisters with cannabis oil in her
luggage now she pled guilty one week ago
and said she packed the cartridges
accidentally now grinder appeared in a
russian court today
but no verdict was reached her next
appearance is in just hours as she faces
10 years in a russian jail
well lebron james who never met a moment
to bash the country that made him a
billionaire he didn't like offered this
trenchant analysis
brittany griner she is in russia she's
been there over 110 days now how can she
feel like america has her back i would
be feeling like do i even want to go
back to america
unreal joining me now is anna's cantor
freedom former center for the boston
celtics and human rights activist
annis you're here tonight because you
have a message for billionaire lebron
james what is it
well he's he's an unappreciative
billionaire you know when i see people
taking their freedom for granted it
breaks my heart i wish i can just you
know buy it to a plane ticket and take
him to some of the countries out there
in the world and he will definitely
appreciate it more but when i hear his
comments i was just not shocked you know
i was like well you know he's been
hitting hating on uh this country for a
long time but the important thing is we
should keep people uh
i i i
it just like kills my heart when i see
comments like this because the thing is
like there there are other side of the
people uh of the world that suffering so
much are going through so many tough
times and i wish that i can show them
what people are going through there
well anna's he knows though i mean
the man has been to china to play
basketball you know he's famously got
upset when anyone would criticize china
or or jeopardize their nba relationship
with the communist party of china so he
knows full well the way other people
live and he doesn't care
so you're being very charitable here
tonight but lebron did try to clean it
up let me just tell you what he tweeted
he said my comments weren't knocking our
beautiful country i was simply saying
how grinder's probably feeling
emotionally along with so many other
emotions long story short hashtag bring
her home uh annis do you buy that
first of all everybody knows that it's a
walk back after he's you know get a lot
of backlashes uh on social media
obviously his pr team try to clean it up
but it's not gonna work you know
and like he needs to understand like you
know uh brittany greiner wrote a letter
to president biden and actually
president biden uh you know wrote a
letter back to her after she was
considering the not to play the national
anthem rest of the year of uh wnba
season um i think people need to
understand uh what's going on and lebron
james i mean he earned his money in this
country he earned his respect he earned
his fame he and this country gives you
everything that you own and you're
unappreciative billionaire and that is
unacceptable
and as a writer at deadspin came after
you tonight saying and his freedom has a
lot of nerve he was critical of lebron
james when he could have been brittany
griner
or worse the piece goes on your native
country turkey revoked your passport for
speaking out against their dictator and
you were stuck overseas with no way back
to america i truly shudder to think what
would have happened had the turkish
government gotten its hands on you
and it's um it's hardly worthy response
but it's actually so stupid that it's
funny i'm your response
i mean
oh my god i lost my career just because
i stand up for the things that i believe
in i actually lost my family last time i
saw my family was back in 2015 because i
was speaking about some of the you know
problems were happening in the turkey so
i did pay the prayer price you know we
always say don't just talk about it be
about it i think you know tweeting about
it is fine and talking give it
interesting fun but what kind of
sacrifices that you're making you know
when you call yourself a human right
activist social justice uh warrior and
stuff right you cannot be going out and
signing a deal with this hypocrite
companies like nike when
you know your shoes are being literally
made by slaves in china that is
unacceptable so i did pay the price what
about lebron
well when you think about some of your
former fellow players
i imagine there's a diversity of thought
about all of these issues um yet people
are afraid to speak out aren't they
oh my god yes yes i'm free i remember
first time i started to speak out about
you know the problems that are happening
in china one of my teammates walked to
me woke up to me in a locker room and
said you know this is your last year in
the league right you are not going to
play a basketball after this year it's
over for you and i was really shocked
i'm like what are you talking about he's
like when you criticize china and you're
an nba player when you criticize nike
you are not going to get another another
job after this but i was very sad i
actually like
re try to reach out to so many other nba
players some and not just an nba other
organizations associations other even
the olympians because he was right
before the beijing olympics i'm like
listen there are so many there's a
genocide happening while we are
dribbling the basketball here in america
please join me let's make this a moment
well what they said broke my heart they
said listen man i think what you're
doing is so courageous we love you we
support you we just cannot do it out
loud and i asked them what do you mean
they said well we have a shoe deals
endorsement deals we have jersey sales
we have we want to get another next
paycheck and i asked him one simple
question put yourself in their shoes if
your mother if your sister or if your
daughter was in those concentration
camps in china getting tortured and
raped every day would you still pick
money over your morals no answer and
it's a shame you know we need to hold
this at this accountable because they
have a huge platform to talk about
whatever they want to talk about they
have a huge platform they inspire
millions of kids out there but they're
picking they're literally picking money
over their morals and principles and
values and as um the globalists all
stick together they're all protecting
china
when's the last time we had that
hollywood blockbuster about mao come out
you know that's never going to be made
so uh and it's we we really appreciate
your speaking out your courage continued
courage on this and so many other issues
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else